Even by the standards of other famous violent
anomalies, SCP-106, better known as The Old
Man, is a complete monster.
Consider this - SCP-096, the Shy Guy, is a
mindless beast that kills out of pure instinct
when people see its face.
SCP-049, the Plague Doctor, kills by accident
with his deadly touch while trying to help.
Even SCP-682 seems to kill because the burning
hatred for all life that resides inside it
is impossible to suppress.
But SCP-106 doesn’t kill out of hatred,
he kills out of love - and what he loves more
than anything else is inflicting pain, misery,
and terror, just for the fun of it.
In case you haven’t seen our video on the
subject, SCP-106 is an invincible, sadistic
old man whose anomalous abilities allow him
to walk through solid surfaces.
As a result, he’s incredibly hard to contain
- making him one of the scarier Keter-class
anomalies in SCP Foundation containment - and
it’s almost impossible to escape if you
end up on his hit list.
But his scariest ability of all is dragging
people into his pocket dimension: A private
hell where he controls both space and time,
and can do awful things to his captured victims
to his heart’s content.
SCP-106 is downright evil, and he couldn’t
be happier about it.
You might assume that there are no hidden
depths to be plumbed when it comes to the
straightforwardly violent monster, but certain
SCP Foundation discoveries about the infamous
Old Man may surprise you.
Meet SCP-978: The Desire Camera.
This anomalous Polaroid Camera has the remarkable
ability to reveal the deepest desire of its
subject, and the Foundation tested the camera
on several employees and anomalies - including
SCP-106.
Now, you might have expected SCP-106’s greatest
desire to be causing more pain, his favorite
activity, but the researchers were shocked
to find out that wasn’t the case at all.
The actual result, according to test logs,
was, quote, “SCP-106 roaming a wheat field.
Appears to be approaching an old farmhouse,
while a woman, appearing to be in her mid-sixties,
welcomes 106.”
It turned out that even a creature of pure
malice like SCP-106 may have some hidden secrets
after all, a prospect that greatly intrigued
Foundation researchers.
While an obscene amount of work had gone into
containing The Old Man and subverting his
powerful anomalous abilities, comparatively
little work had gone into his origins.
And when the Foundation actually started digging,
they were surprised to find that the rabbit
hole was far, far deeper than they’d ever
imagined.
Much like the Joker, The Old Man’s origin
story is multiple choice.
Out of the reams of research into SCP-106’s
origin, we’ve narrowed it down to the three
most plausible possibilities for how a creature
like The Old Man could come to exist: The
Divergent Species Theory, the Scranton Theory,
and the Corporal Lawrence Theory.
And today we’re going to explore all of
them.
First, let’s look at the Divergent Species
Theory.
The main basis for this theory is information
gleaned from a tale known as “Once But Not
Now.”
This tale is seen as a collection of memories
from the atrophied mind of The Old Man, detailing
his origins thousands of years prior.
It’s worth remembering that a lot of these
memories are, of course, highly subjective
and interpretive.
If they are to be taken as the authentic memories
of the Old Man, then it is also important
to note that - as a deranged, compulsive sadist
- details of his memories are possibly unreliable.
That being said, according to the reports
contained within “Once But Not Now”, The
Old Man was once a member of a hominid family
similar to that of humans, but displaying
the anomalous powers we’ve come to expect
from SCP-106: Enhanced strength, corrosive
mucus, and the ability to pass through solid
objects.
In the documents, it is implied that the primary
source of prey for the Old Man’s species
was actually neanderthals.
They had basic tribal cultures that allowed
them to organize hunting parties for the purpose
of bringing food back to their camps.
They even had a semblance of socially-enforced
laws - leaving members of their tribe to starve
after they committed murder against their
own species.
If things had played out differently, this
species may have stuck around, perhaps even
surpassing humanity and becoming the dominant
species on Earth: An entire thriving culture
of SCP-106.
However, as time passed, the neanderthals
were eventually hounded to extinction.
This destroyed the primary food source for
SCP-106’s species, which - if you have even
a basic familiarity with evolutionary biology
- never bodes well for a species.
As The Old Man’s species turned its attention
to humanity, it found they weren’t nearly
as easy to prey upon.
As a result, their species slowly fell into
decline and eventually slipped into near extinction.
The Old Man, most likely the last of his kind,
went into a state of hibernation within a
tree.
He remained in the tree for what may have
been thousands of years, before eventually
climbing out into a world that had long since
forgotten anything like him had ever existed.
The Old Man woke up into a strange new world,
filled with alien structures and garish lights.
He wandered, confused and hungry, haunted
by the knowledge that he was the last one
left of his kind.
He wandered around the new world until he
found what he described as “a nest” - likely
just a normal, human home.
He became distressed by the structures and
lights around him, until finally happening
upon a food source that he hungrily ate.
This food source turned out to be a human
infant.
Not long after that, he was apprehended by
figures described as the “men in white coats”
who are likely to be agents of the SCP Foundation.
He was contained not long after that.
These days, his only motivating factor is
the search for pain and anguish - the only
things that can give this very, very old man
any semblance of feelings anymore.
Of course, this is actually the least popular
of the three theories.
But it does pose a rather disturbing question:
If ever there was a whole species of SCP-106,
is it really possible that our species would
be able to outlast them?
The second most popular theory was that SCP-106
was not only once human, but an extremely
important Foundation researcher.
Namely, Dr. Robert Scranton.
If that name sounds familiar to you, it may
be because you’ve heard of the famous Scranton
Reality Anchors.
These devices, inspired by Scranton, have
been the Foundation’s greatest tools in
combating the anomalous effects of reality
warpers.
And, if the Scranton Theory about the origin
of 106 is to be believed, it’s darkly ironic
that it would be a reality-warping anomaly
that would bring Dr. Scranton to his unfortunate
end.
The horrors began on January 2nd, in the year
2000, when Dr. Scranton and his wife, Dr.
Anna Lang, were testing a new technology:
the Lang-Scranton Stabilizer.
This was the technology that would lay the
groundwork for the Reality Anchors that would
later be created in Scranton’s name.
However, the stabilizer was ironically anything
but stable, and caused what is known as a
momentary Class-C "Broken Entry" Wormhole.
Scranton was sucked into the wormhole, and
transported to a pocket dimension known as
SCP-3001, or “The Red Reality.”
Many people assumed Scranton was dead, but
the reality was far more horrific.
SCP-3001, which the still-living Scranton
and the control pad of the stabilizer were
sucked into, was a kind of empty, infinitely-extending
void.
The laws of reality did not apply in the darkened
void of 3001: There was no space, no light,
no passage of time.
It was the absence of all existence, except
for Scranton who was the one speck of existence
trapped inside.
As whatever passed for “time” went on,
Scranton could only speak to a small audio
recorder embedded in the console.
It became his only company, the one thing
anchoring him to some semblance of sanity.
But of course, that couldn’t last forever.
As he came to terms with the reality of his
situation, Dr. Scranton became overtaken by
fear, and then despair.
He started to lose hope that he would ever
exit the pocket dimension of SCP-3001, and
his coherent speech became terrified, disconnected
ramblings as his mind fell apart.
He tried to end his life 184 times while trapped
there, but it never worked.
He took the damage of each attempt, slowly
becoming unrecognizable, but there was no
death to grant him escape from SCP-3001.
As time went on, the very state of reality
within the Red Reality began to decay.
Matter started to become anti-matter, and
Robert Scranton felt himself coming apart
at the seams and floating into nothingness.
He was still conscious and very much aware
as his personality - perhaps even his very
soul - fractured and drifted away with his
body.
In total, he spent almost six years inside
the broken pocket dimension, though this probably
felt like an eternity to him.
Eventually, even the console vanished from
the Red Reality and returned back to our own,
leaving whatever was left of Robert Scranton
truly alone.
Those who loved him prefer to believe that
he’s now as close to dead as is possible
within SCP-3001, but people who believe in
the Scranton Theory have different ideas…
Dr. Robert Scranton - or rather, whatever
he became - was headstrong.
He wanted to escape the Red Reality at any
cost so he could be reunited with his wife,
Dr. Anna Lang.
Through sheer force of willpower, Dr. Scranton
pulled his disparate matter back together,
but it didn’t come back in the way it used
to be.
There was something wrong.
Terribly wrong.
He was now something less than human: SCP-106.
Scranton, a man who’d spent his life developing
technology to keep reality consistent, was
about to build his own reality.
He would build, destroy, and rebuild, again
and again.
He would create a perfect reality for him
and his beloved Anna - which would later become
his trademark pocket dimension.
But when Anna saw the monster he’d become,
she was horrified by him.
His very touch destroyed her, his corrosive
mucus melting her away.
All that was left was the monster he’d become.
The Old Man, SCP-106.
Of course, there’s one more theory about
the origin of SCP-106.
If ever you’ve heard the wall-walking monster
referred to as Uncle Larry, this next story
is why.
In fact, it’s the most widely believed of
all the SCP-106 origin theories: The Corporal
Lawrence Theory.
So, who is Corporal Lawrence?
We actually know very little about the man,
aside from the fact he was a military officer
during World War One.
Our knowledge of him comes from firsthand
accounts of the soldiers serving under him
in the trenches.
The Corporal was described as a plain, aloof,
and vacant man, with a tendency to stare.
Many of the soldiers disliked him on account
of his incredibly flat personality, but perhaps
even more so because Lawrence always seemed
to be followed by the smell of rot.
Strange incidents also seemed to follow him
around - like soldiers in his barracks seeing
greater numbers of sicknesses like trench
foot.
It was almost as if he was cursed.
And perhaps he was.
One fateful day, Lawrence and his men needed
to raid an enemy trench.
They infiltrated the trench, and found that
everyone there was dead, and covered in a
corrosive, black slime.
Worse still, Corporal Lawrence discovered
a strange, black hole in the trench, filled
with the same black substance.
He then collapsed into this hole, before climbing
out, clearly shaken by the experience.
After that, everything went downhill.
Corporal Lawrence appeared to completely change
his personality, becoming a perpetually-grinning
eccentric with a head full of strangely morbid
and sadistic thoughts.
At a certain point, his body seemed to reproduce
the same corrosive mucus he fell into, causing
pain and sickness to his fellow soldiers wherever
he went.
In the end, after the horrific deaths of some
of the soldiers working under him, Corporal
Lawrence and his men were apprehended and
interred at a military hospital.
Not long after though, he disappeared, along
with the rest of his men.
The only trace that remained was on the former
Corporal Lawrence’s hospital bed: Traces
of the corrosive, black mucus, and a ring
of human teeth - pulled from the heads of
every single person on the ward.
The next time he was seen, Corporal Lawrence
truly was no more.
Only SCP-106 remained, and in his own sick
little way, he’d never been happier.
And there you have it, the three most popular
theories into the origin of SCP-106.
Which, if any, do you think is the most likely
theory?
Or do you have one of your own?
Let us know down in the comments.
And remember: Keep an eye on the walls.
You never know when the Old Man will drop
in for a visit...
Now check out “SCP-106 - The Old Man Escape”
and “SCP-3001 - Red Reality” for a deeper
exploration into some of the topics and concepts
discussed in this video.